Hey, what's going on? It's bill bar.
Just checking in on
you on a Thursday here.
Whatever the fuck it is. The hell is
the God damn date here man. So you know,
fuck. Can I turn the third down here in
Louisiana down here on the buggy. Easy.
We just rolled into town today and I'm
just going to do my little half hour bull
shit here before I play a couple of
classic clips from the Monday morning
podcast,
blackened yesteryear back in yesteryear
back before back when baby seals had
enough fish in the ocean to eat right
back when apples would turn brown when
they went bad. I still think we will
make our own salmon at that point.
Man Made Salmon just stirring it up in
a petri dish. Would you care for a bike?
Um, anyways, so, uh,
the tour has been going fantastic.
Um,
this all, all these jokes, man, this is,
this is how you put together
a standup back there, right?
You get on a God damn fucking bus and
you just do shows every night for two
weeks and it's over one weekend,
one weekend. I'm telling you,
it's like going to gym. You go to a
gym the first day like, oh my God,
I don't want to do this.
And then a weekend you feel like
a monster unless you'd like me.
You Bet your bottom for months because
you're, you're almost 47 years of age,
right? But as a different thing.
All right, here we get the,
I note that I wasn't even trying to,
it's going to be like, hey, you know,
it's different.
But I went home.
MMM.
So anyways, what's going on
in the world? Have nothing.
We have another controversy.
Everybody. What is it? What is it?
Is it that the oceans are fished out?
Is it that our food supply
slowly being turned into poison?
Is it that there was this maybe
like what three fucking banks left?
Is that what it is? No, it isn't.
Some fucking guy who plays captain America
and another guy who plays a fucking
electric man or whatever the hell they
play. I don't watch these fucking movies.
The superhero movies, they were asked to
describe some character, the black widow,
and they jokingly said she's a slut.
She's a whore, right. And, and,
and everybody's all fucking up in arms
about it and they have to apologize.
Nobody has to apologize for fucking
drilling for oil and actually accidentally
ruining the fucking water supply.
They don't even have to answer
questions during the town meetings.
They just sent somebody down there to
stare at the person who's now fucking
glowing green cause they had the nerve
to take a shower in their own fucking
house.
There's no apology coming from there.
But these guys here who walk around and
fucking under rose and make some stupid
ass joke right at the end of
a press conference, listen
to these fucking morons.
Somebody roads.
Well it's nice of Chris Evans and Jeremy
Renner to let us know they're super
gross.
Oh,
can you imagine driving cross country
with somebody who says super gross and
misogynistic way to go
bros. Another one. Oh dear.
Now that Jeremy Renner and Chris
Evans or making tasteless jokes, no.
Now Jeremy Renner and Chris
Evans or making tasteless
jokes about the only women
woman in the franchise.
Okay.
Chris Evans and Jeremy [inaudible]
recent comments on the blackboard.
We're beyond, beyond disturbing,
okay. And misogynistic.
Unreal.
So then they both had to issue apologies.
The guys who walk around and under rules,
right?
And Eat fucking proteins
and salads so they can,
they can talk their guts into
these fucking tight suits
after wishing or apology
about making fun of a fictitious woman.
Yesterday they were asked
about the rumors, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah. Here we go.
Here's the apologies.
Uh,
yesterday we were asked about the real
ways that black letter law had to be in a
relationship with both
Hawkeye and Captain America.
Can you believe this is a natural apology
as the accurate actor who portrays hawk?
I'd like to apologize to the character
black widow for suggesting she was a
whore. You know what I
mean? You know what I love?
I love that they're acting
like there are no horse.
That word exists for a reason.
You know there's horse.
I'm in Louisiana,
a fucking New Orleans.
I'll show you how fucking straight
of a does that make me misogynistic?
This is the dumb ish. Anyways,
I liked renders apology.
He goes, I'm sorry for that tasteless
joke about a fictional character.
I'm sorry that sorry.
I am sorry that this tasteless joke about
a fictional character offended anyone.
Can you read between the lines? You're
fucking morons. That's what he's,
I feel like he's saying it was
not to be serious in a way.
Just poking fun during an
exhausting and tedious press tour.
These guys were asked the same five
questions for like nine hours in a row,
and then they called the woman who
doesn't exist of fucking widow, a widow,
no fucking whore and a slut. And now
they have to apologize as real people.
They have to apologize to real women
about the fictitious woman that they
labeled as a whore.
You know what I mean?
You know what's funny is that if there
was actually a real woman walking around
doing half the shit, I don't even know
what black widow does, but let's just,
you know, if they live up to the photo,
what does a black widow spider, right?
It fucking banks had guy gets his Joses
in him and then fucking kills them.
You know what I mean?
You know what that sounds like to me.
That sounds like that movie monster,
right?
What did she got an Oscar for that?
I want to see that.
I want to see a guy who plays a Gigolo
and goes around and murders fucking hard
up housewives. I want to hear that be
called a fucking brave performance.
It was so brave. He didn't wear any
aftershave during that performance.
Have you ever seen that movie?
That movie is one of the
funniest fucking movies ever.
They literally turn her into a victim.
You know what I mean?
I had and in the end,
like this love story,
she's sitting there crying
and I'm supposed to cry with
her cause she didn't fly
in love. This murderous
sociopath. Um, you know,
but she wasn't wearing makeup
and as she was killing men.
So evidently that's a brave,
it's a wonderful thing.
Um, anyways, if you're finally
somebody's rational, this woman wrote,
if you're offended by that joke,
that Renner and Evan's made
about a fictional character,
please re reevaluate your life and relax.
Exactly.
Someone else wrote Renner.
Did not sound sincere at all.
Does he really owe you an
apology? Huh? Are you a superhero?
You know, being a superhero and a
female has always been difficult for me.
First of all,
I possess no super powers to speak of.
And I don't know if there's a second,
but if it is,
I'm sure it's harder than whatever guys
go through consomme and apologize to me
please. Um, anyways, who gives a shit?
Okay,
let me come on. There were actors,
there were all horse, right?
Do you think anyone ones want to walk
around in those fucking suits? You know,
you fucking package all fucking,
you know, snuggled up there.
I Dunno who the fuck knows.
I'm waiting for them to somehow
then do something on white males.
I actually read one thing
was saint look shirt.
They were both joking but considering
they're white males and then it just
becomes, let's take the thing that we
know is a joke and now take it seriously.
Um,
which is going to bring up,
I'm sure the whole argument that
if a guy sleeps around, you know,
he's called the stud. If a woman sleeps
around, she's called a whore in it.
And that totally makes sense to me.
And I'm allowed to have this opinion
without you fucking having your hair.
Fucking curlews go flying across the
Goddamn Room. All right. Fucking relax.
My opinion does not affect anything.
All right?
I go along with that because there's no
skill level and falls in a woman getting
laid is there, I'm not saying
you can fuck anybody you want,
but she can go out and get laid. I don't
think it's that God damn difficult,
you know, and less a, you know,
I don't know what your deal is.
Let's just so fucking know
and knowing you would have to,
big guys will fuck anything.
Why is that?
I don't know why, but all I know
is as a guide to get laid is a,
is a fucking skill.
You've got to learn how to do what
you got to have like a fucking,
you've got to have a good thousand
of bats under your fucking belt.
Just exist at that point.
If you're lucky,
a hitting about a buck 40.
If you look like Ron Howard
like I did, I mean, you're,
you've already been sent
down to AAA. Um, yeah.
Oh, Jesus Christ. So unfucking believable.
What a what a fucking way. Oh yeah.
I actually, I'm wasting time on
the podcast talking about this.
This has become like an every week thing.
Like I don't understand
who the fuck they are.
Even apologizing to the
people that comment.
That's just ridiculous.
You know,
I'm never going to see another one of
his movies until the next person offends
me and then I'll forget what they said
and then I'll go see their movies.
Anyways. Um, anyways, let's, let's,
let's get off this stupid subject. Uh,
what was the last time I talked to you?
I talked to you on Monday,
so I believe I was heading into fucking
Knoxville who dares to call me on the,
during the fucking podcast.
I have the most generic fucking bring.
Hold on a second.
Okay.
Jesus Christ. All right, so here we go.
Yeah, we go back to the podcast.
I don't know what that is.
I hope that's not business related. I
am not a good businessman. All right,
so last I talked to you,
we were heading into Knoxville.
Knoxville was an amazing,
um, amazing show. Uh,
do Chattanooga.
Jesus Christ,
don't sleep on that fucking place.
Um,
we went there and had great food,
unbelievable show.
And then uh,
we ended up hanging out this place,
which of course I already can't
remember the fucking name of it.
I tweeted about it. Do I have the
memory of, of a, of a fucking inset?
Unreal.
Now I literally have to look up when I
tweeted about at a place that I went to
and had a great time when I was in
Chattanooga. I'll tell you all about it.
Other than than Ah, right.
I know. I heard the ring
Steve Jobs.
You fucking cunt.
I bet you came up with that right to
have it fucking ring and ring and ring.
And if it doesn't, if they don't
pick up, it will continue to ring.
Um, all right. Where the hell is it?
Do I really fucking retweet this much?
What an asshole.
Oh Geez.
Is where is it dude?
You guys been watching ESPN by the way,
trying to fill the hours during
baseball season. I was watching,
I was sitting there eating breakfast and
they had the thing and they had a bit
on there called is it gangster or is it
[inaudible]? It's just like, you know,
you know, I think ESPN should
do, I think they should fuck,
I'd have sports center in the morning
and then while they're waiting for more
games to start in the afternoon, they
should just take a nap. They should just,
you know,
turn the fucking thing off,
show some old sports bloopers
and they should all, you know,
take off this suits and ties,
you know,
put the dress socks and they're wingtips
tips and they should just all just take
a fucking nap and stop pretending things
are happening between the hours of
11:00 AM and 5:00 PM nothing
is going on. All right, go out.
Go get yourself a fucking Taco. You know
the sitting there talking about, uh,
that, what's his face that
Jamison, what's his face?
They're doing this thing about him.
Did he or did he not steal those stupid
fucking crab legs actually tweeted about
that and somebody fucking
took me seriously. I will.
Can you build a franchise around a man
who may or may own dot stolen some crab
legs? I'll tell you if I'm Tampa Bay,
I'm sure she reconsidering Jamison.
Winston is my first pick.
Why only needs to look at the
Hernandez situation in New England?
How ridiculous is that?
Somebody actually wrote back to me like,
I'm first degree murder is a little more,
a little worse than fucking
stealing crab legs. You know, Jesus,
you know what, I'm not gonna be able to
find the name of this fucking place. Um,
I went to a place in Chattanooga,
we could smoke a cigar play.
You could fucking bull. And
I'm the worst. I swear to God.
I tweeted about it. I got an
I can't find, I can't find it.
I had a great time there.
I can tell you that, uh,
good food and all that shit.
And last night we were in Shreveport.
I thought I was playing at that place
that Elvis and Jerry Lee Lewis did. I did.
And I played another place like
the strand right down the street,
which was awesome. Um, Elvis
was never there, but I,
I did learn when I was in
Shreveport, they have a, uh,
some sort of convention center there and
that's the first place where somebody
announced Elvis has left the building.
That's the first time that was ever
uttered. And uh, if you're a nerd like me,
that was a cool thing to learn about, you
know. So anyways, I'm here in the, uh,
the big easy, uh, the big
sleazy as they call it. And uh,
I got a show here tonight,
uh,
really looking forward to it and I'm
hanging out here over the next couple of
days somehow trying to figure out how
to stay in shape in this God forsaken
place. I swear to God they
fry everything down here.
Is the thing about the south too, it's,
it's such cheap fucking living down here.
Do you know when I was in Chattanooga
they had a sign that said 1-800-DIVORCE
and underneath it it said basic divorce,
350 bucks.
Can you believe? I mean, I know
that that's just the lawyers fee,
but you figure we what that is.
That is like one of the,
that will be like if honey
booboo, you know, someone
from her family got divorced,
you know, I mean, what do you, what
are your breaking up at that point?
Can I get that last
chocolate frosted doughnut?
Are you going to have it all
right if you take in that, that I,
I want to get that face cloth right.
Fucking lawyers just sitting in there,
you know, staring down at his shoes. You
know he's dressed like colonel Sanders.
Just get some weird mustache
you guys bought. Darn.
You settle it up. No, no, no. Wait, wait.
I gotta I gotta change up southern voices.
Yeah, I've got a couple more here. Um,
let's see. Do you want that? Uh,
do you want that? That was up to
each tank top. You want that or,
okay. You have, okay. If you
have that, that I'm getting
the keep on trucking April
and that'll be yet, and the other guys
just like, all right, there you go.
Signed, sealed divorce. Done.
That'll be 350 bucks. Oh Man,
I thought you said $3 and 50 cents.
I had no fucking idea.
I'm gonna have to go across the
street and get myself alone. Um,
that's the place you get divorced.
Everybody. Chattanooga, Tennessee.
I can't believe I can't remember the name
of that fucking place I went to. Dude,
you went in, you smoke cigars. It's right
across the street from the college that,
uh,
terrellowens went to,
which of course I can't remember
the name of that either. And uh,
they had outback. I gotta look this
fucking place up out back. They had a,
uh,
what do you call those things that white
people who don't have any money live in
a trailer.
I had a trailer airstream trailer that
they had hollowed out and they made like
a smoking room out of it.
And we sat in that fucking thing.
I've been watching a bunch of
NBA playoffs. It's killing me.
Versie and fucking La Headbutt
that God Damn Basketball Jones,
they just so fucking into
it and it's just like,
do you realize that the
Stanley Cup playoffs are
going on the greatest playoffs
that exists just fucking
guys. You flipping out about
three pointers and layups,
you put on fucking hockey. These guys
are taking a stick to their head,
skating off the spitting out teeth and
then they come back five minutes later,
that shit on the Knicks.
We comes out with his fucking broken leg
that happens like every other game in
hockey playoffs
back in the day pre
like HIV and that shit.
They used to stitch guys up right on the
bench and the guide be getting stitched
up and is a dude who hit him skates by
the guy getting stitched up but talk shit
to them. And they got Willis Reed
now, you know, obviously Willis Reed,
he beat up the whole fucking Lakers at
the same time. I'm not saying the guy,
but I'm saying I don't fucking,
I don't know what I'm talking about.
I'm just so sick of fucking watching hoop.
It just bores me to tears.
I do like watching, um, uh,
um, the guys from Oakland,
they're golden state.
I do like watching them. Um, but
I, I just, I've had enough man.
It's like I just watched march madness.
I'm all fucking hooped out. And you know,
I'm sitting there just flipping back and
forth and caught the end of the ducks.
I know that they swept, um, look at me.
I don't even know what they swept
Winnepeg and I know that a Ottawa beat the
Canadians last night,
you know, be amazing.
If they went to tonight in Montreal,
then all of a sudden all those frenchies
would get really fucking nervous. Like,
Oh fuck,
are we going to drop four in a row?
We can Trump four in a row to the costs
down the street that are actually a
capital of this country.
As we're up here walking around acting
like we're the capitol when they're
actually the capital, are they really
going to come back and do this?
And if they do,
when do we boot Carey price out of town?
Because that's what we do is Canadian
fence that was fucking spoiled brats
spoiled anymore. You know what I love
about them is just like fucking 20,
25 year olds with no recollection
of ever winning a cup.
It's happening right now up there,
all of those,
all that shit talking about
all their fucking cups.
It's going away because now there's
competition and they can't run the table
anymore. It's fucking phenomenal. And uh,
I really hope they go the rest of
my life and never wouldn't want.
I really don't wish that on anybody other
than Canadian fans. I don't know why.
They're just fun to hate.
You know what's funny too is actually get
upset then I fucking talk. She is like,
why would you get upset? My team's not
even in the playoffs. Playoffs, you know?
But you know what?
We have wanted fucking Stanley Cup at
least in the last 20 fucking years.
I know that you guys want a bunch yet,
but
I want to three o'clock as well.
They should play when they
show Canadians highlights,
they should show Bill Haley
and the comments and they
should go all the way back
to like Butoh, booboo,
booboo, booboo, you know,
maybe look three stooges music.
Wow. Wow, wow, wow, blah
blah, Bah Bah Bah Bah Bob.
Sorry. Alright, Chattanooga,
here we go. Chattanooga said Gar.
Okay.
Bowling bar. Let's see
if I can find this thing.
I'm actually doing like a
fucking 10 minute commercial
on it now because I can't
find the goddamn thing. Come on. Oh yeah.
I'll tell you everything slowed down
here in the south. Even the Internet,
even that fucking Internet,
um,
south side social, that's where I
went. If you're ever in Chattanooga,
you can smoke a cigar outside in this
fucking air stream while you're watching a
goddamn game. They got,
um, they got horse shoes,
they got bowling, they got pool, they
got games. I never even heard of.
They got Midwest Games, southern games,
any fucking thing you want to do? Um,
they had whiskey.
Slushies what more do I got to say?
Whatever. Fucking, I'll tell
you this, right if, whatever.
Okay.
Uh, college, um,
Trent Reznor went to whatever the
fuck his name is. Terrellowens uh,
just give tickets to a game. Go down,
right and right across the street,
south side, short social, going
there before the game. Smoke a stove,
he'd drink a beer and then go
across street. Watch the game.
You can actually walk up to the fence
and watch it. Like it's the, uh,
the depression era. And we had a
great time there. And, um, anyways,
then we went on to,
uh, went on to Memphis.
A bunch of people were in town.
Uh,
yeah,
I can drop names here,
but there was somebody in town
for the Memphis grizzly game. Um,
and he hung out with us talking
hoop and fucking version law head.
We'll losing this shit. And uh,
I was to just as a sports fan,
but they on a whole other level because
they just fucking, um, you know,
crazy oop fans. They were
asked him like, boats,
what was it like to play defense against
Michael Jordan and all that shit. So, uh,
we had an amazing time and uh,
it's been, it's been phenomenal to,
to really, to, to go through all of these
fucking towns that I've never been to.
Shreveport was the shit. Um,
rather than waking up today,
pulling into New Orleans and after
New Orleans, just to let you know,
the only place I need help anybody came
out to a show so far on this tour that
is enjoyed it. Could you, if
you know anybody in Mississippi,
could you please let them know
about the show in Jackson?
That is the only fucking one I'm,
I'm really trying to,
uh,
to get some inroads in their Mississippi
just seems like its, its, its,
its complete own deal
more so than even Texas.
The Texas walks around and
they talk a bunch of shit.
You know what are you interested? Yeah.
In America anymore. You booking taxis,
right?
You fuck you all right with you God damn
baby gap stores and all of that Shit
and all those whores walking
around with their makeup. Oh God.
Do I have to apologize to Dallas now?
Um,
well cause the woman puts on clown
makeup. She's a whore. If a man does it.
Hello.
All right. Can I say this to
people in general? Fucking grow up.
Bunch of God damn babies. Give a fuck
about something that matters. Right.
That fruit causes cancer
now. Right. How about that?
I'll just throw that out there. I don't
have to apologize to the fruit industry.
Um, now when you say fruit, what are you
saying? Are you actually talking about it?
Are you making fun of a group of
people? I want an apology. Ooh.
Um, I'd love to find who
these fucking people are.
Go out and just interview
them and you think, why?
Why were you offended personally?
And then go into their apps.
They fucking bullshit rhetoric and then
I just would gradually break them down.
What's going on in your life right
now? Huh? Are you happy at work?
Are you happy in your relationship
and you're not all right. Yeah. Great.
So rather than deal with that,
you're going to fucking talk about
these two guys that, you know,
they dress up like fucking,
uh, aqua man and uh,
the ozone layer guy, right? You're
going to get fucking upset about them.
Ozone layer guy, that's a good
new fucking superhero, right?
Okay.
Ozone layer guy, he's got
a hole in his heart, right?
That's the hole in the ozone layer.
Just can't give it to love.
And how he stopped the criminals is he
just sucks out the fucking atmosphere.
Everybody in the whole
planet faints and then he,
you revives everybody at the same time
except for the bad guy. And then people,
you know, you know, society never
understands the superheroes. It'd be like,
you know, I understand that
he has to, uh, stop crying,
but does he have to to deprive all
of our brains of oxygen? I mean,
at the end of the day, uh, you
know, despite the fact, yeah,
you're, you're, you're, you're,
um, oh gee, I don't know
your, your mission I guess is,
is a noble one. Let me, don't get me
wrong, I want to clean up the streets too,
but I really don't need to
pass out every 20 minutes.
So Ozone Guy, if you are listening,
right. And of course he's like, he likes,
he's like the weatherman on that shelf.
Right?
But he parks his hair in a different
science and nobody can see it except for
some broad,
right.
She fucking figures it out and
she starts blowing them, you know,
in the hall of justice and like a broom
closet and she's just like, you know,
when,
when are we going to,
when are you going to introduce me to
all your other fucking superhero friends?
And, uh, he's all insecure because
he's not as cool as superman. Right.
Of the green lantern. What does the
Green Lantern Dude does it does. He,
does he actually have a lantern? Does
it shoot out green lights? Come on.
You fucking nerd. Somebody was skin
tags knows the answer to that, right?
Yeah.
Oh, that was me. That was really
mean. I go to the gym every day.
It's just become a pop me nights.
And if you don't want to be fatty,
well you go to the gym every day. You
can't. That's what I'm doing after this,
everybody, I'm going to the God
damn gym. I'm going to the gym.
I'm going to a fucking a gym down south,
which means they have a fucking,
they have a stair masters that somebody
one on card sharks a long time ago.
And after Katrina, it floated by and
these people sprayed some Rustoleum on.
I gotta take a picture of this
God damn gym they have in there.
They do actually have some,
they have some dumbbells. So a,
I could do some damage in there. They do
have a treadmill, but it's like that. Uh,
remember those old school treadmills when
they first came out where it felt like
the tread on the mill sets
of proper terminology.
It was just a little bit loose and you
almost like do a face plant like every
like fifth step. Um, they
got one of those in there.
One of the ones, like if somebody who
weighed too much leaned against it,
the entire front of it would
just fucking break off. That's,
that's what I'm working with.
Um, so anyways, I got to read,
I've got one fucking advertisement
on this. Okay. Which God knows.
You guys know this is entertaining.
Oh good. We get to listen to bill.
Try to read out loud. I'm going
to try to slow down the pace here.
Yeah.
And see if I can actually, uh,
read this correctly. Zip Recruiter,
everyone.
Are you hiring but not sure where to
find the best candidate as a business
owner, I can tell you that your
company is not only as fuck,
I just can't do it. All right. Oh, I got
into a sentence and a half. All right,
let's just read it. The normal speed.
Ziprecruiter, everybody are you hiring?
But not sure where to find the best
candidates. As a business owner,
I can tell you that your company is
only as good as the people you hire.
I can also tell you that posting your
job in one place isn't enough to find
quality candidates,
but when you're short staffed,
there's no time to deal with
dozens of different jobs sites.
You don't need that shit until now.
Thanks to ziprecruiter.com you can post.
You can post to 100 plus job sites with
one single click and have the highest
possible chance of finding that perfect
candidate just post once and within 24
hours, watch your candidates
Rolan Zip recruiter's easy to use.
Interface what?
Ziprecruiter's easy to use.
Interface period.
Ziprecruiter.
Ziprecruiter has an to use interface.
Ziprecruiter has been used by over 300,000
businesses and you can try it right
now for absolutely free.
Getting the right people for
your company is so important.
So try zip recruiter and get your perfect
candidates before they go to somebody
else. Today. You can try
ZipRecruiter for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/burr,
ziprecruiter.com/burr. Again,
ziprecruiter.com/burr Bravo,
uniform, Romeo, Romeo. Um,
all right, let's see. That was
pretty painless, wasn't it?
Not really. Um, so anyways,
I got New Orleans tonight and um,
we're here for actually going to stay
here for a couple of days and uh,
we were actually thinking of going
to the Pelicans golden state game on
Saturday, but, uh, we have to make our
way up to Huntsville. So everybody,
your mission,
all right,
if you live down south and maybe
you live up north and you have that,
those cousins you never talked to,
if they're down there in Mississippi,
if you know how to somehow get in touch
with these people and get people to come
out to a show. I'm also, I want to thank
everybody who's been buying the, uh,
the Billie Bible belt tour poster,
just basically me preaching
to people 80 years ago.
It's basically a
preacher's head, uh, body,
and they took the head off and put my
head on it and that people really seem to
be loving that.
And a lot of people have seen pictures
of the poster and they would like to get
one. Um, I have, I can't sell them yet.
If I have any leftover I will and the
bonuses, they will all be autograft.
So whatever I have leftover after the
tour immediately I'll put it up on a
billboard.com. Um, I'm not fucking you
here. It's a high quality piece of paper.
It's a, I forget how big it is, but
it's, it's pretty uh, pretty impressive.
And I'm, if I do have any lefts,
um, I will autograph all of them.
And uh,
if you guys want to get them,
you'd be doing me a solid cause if not
that just going to sit in my fucking
garage and my wife's going to give
me shit. All right, that's the deal.
That's what happens.
Everything ends up in the garage.
Everything ends up in the garage unless
you get rid of it. And then what happens?
You don't have any room for your
fucking car to go into the garage.
And if you live in La,
what most people do is they turned
their garage into another room.
Cause they just look at it
like, well, hey, you know,
would never fucking rains out here. Oh,
speaking of that Shit, Jesus Christ,
Jesus Christ, can somebody do a
rain dance for California? You know,
I thought it was being right.
Smart investing into fucking real estate.
And even though I knew California,
I mean Los Angeles was a desert.
I mean, Hey, you know, uh, Jeez,
I'm actually thinking about selling
my house and going back to renting.
So when the shit hits the fan,
when that last drop of water comes out,
I can just walk away from at least.
Um,
I'll tell you what's some amazing that
I saw when we drive them from Memphis
down to Shreveport, south of,
uh, Little Rock, Arkansas.
Um,
it kill me too to drive through that city,
not do stand up there and fucking kill me.
I'm going to have to add that if I do
a, if I do a tour, starting little rock,
maybe cut through Oklahoma and do some
shit like that, I'll figure something out.
But, um, that whole fucking,
you can't believe I actually understand
why people in like some of these states
in the middle of the country
don't believe in global warming.
If you see the fucking land, they are
living on that shit. I mean, granted,
I was just zipping down the highway,
but all I saw was nothing but trees.
And you knew when they have trees with
them, wild pigs, that's good eating.
I'll tell you they'll fuck up a farm, but
that isn't good. Fucking eight. And uh,
that's all my bucket list.
I want to, I want to shoot a
pig on a shoot. A wild pig.
All right. In the fucking ass. Um,
picking up buck shot out of a
pork shoulder. Come on. We've all,
we've all dreamed of doing that
avenue. We all right. Anyways, uh,
I didn't even get to any of that shit.
You know,
I couldn't find the stuff that you guys,
you guys sent me on,
on a, I almost said on the Twitter.
That's how fucking old I am. I couldn't,
I couldn't find what you
guys sent me on the Twitter,
the shit that you wanted me to rant about.
Oh,
you know what one person wanted
me to talk about was the, uh,
that w n a couple that got into the fight.
Yeah.
Where the hell is it? Come on bill.
Don't blow it. Don't be a fucking moron.
Like always. Where is it? Where is it?
Come on. Oh, I don't know
what the fuck happened.
I guess there's two women that play
on a team in Phoenix and they're in a
relationship and they're
actually engaged and um,
Brittany something or
other and they got it.
They fucking threw down
in the house and uh,
they, they just, they
couldn't break them up.
The couldn't bring me talking about to
fucking athletes competing at the top of
their game. All right. You don't
get there by Quinten do you?
So these two fucking type a people,
I guess go at it and they just kicked
the shit out of each other and then even
their relatives finally
had to call the cops.
And this is the coolest
part in the end of it.
They neither one of them press charges.
So all they got booked on was suspicion
of beating the shit out of somebody else.
Um,
that's a solid move right there.
I think in, in the end, I think
there's still love there, right?
Neither want to press charges.
So you figure if I'm a cop,
so I got to look at that. Like that's
like offsetting penalties. You know,
we've got multiple files on the play.
Personal file.
Brittany watch her face for
punching to Lula so-and-so
right in the mouth.
She said she had a tooth mark on her own,
a fist and we got another personal
foul on the other side. Uh,
kicked to the clam by Talulah.
What's her face?
Those penalties offset replay the down.
That's how I look
at it.
I think it's fine.
Obviously they're going to have to
find a more mature way to settle their
problems. Why can't you just
do that? You know what I mean?
If you're in a relationship,
you're in a same sex relationship.
Shouldn't they be allowed if
they want to, to just, you know,
cause now you're talking to essentially,
um,
well I guess you'd have to be in the
same way class. All right. Um, I'm,
I'm lobbying for this right now,
just so we can keep the jail's
not as overcrowded. How about it,
if you're in a same sex relationship,
if your partner is in
the same weight class,
is you all right?
If you guys throw down not enough,
one beats the shit out of the other,
but if he bolts, just say, you know,
you want to fucking do this,
right? They fucking go at it.
And if they're just fine,
he's just settle it the way it did
with your older brother. Right.
You just fought and then that was it. You
fight till you're tired, you were done.
And the cops don't have to show
up. There's no problems, you know,
that'd be in Debbie. Okay.
That'd be a nice thing. Right.
Oh Jeez. I wonder if I could
do that. You know what I mean?
What if,
what if your wife is a UFC champion?
Okay. And you don't have any training
like me, right? All you have is a,
I'm going to get you in a headlock.
Why you get me in a headlock?
I'll never squeeze harder wins,
okay? If you were in a relationship,
you didn't know how to fight,
but your wife was a a,
a UFC champion.
Mrs. Such a stupid thing because
you're going to loose instantly.
If you guys watched any of those videos
where a, what's your face? Ronda Rousey.
There's always some dumb, goofy guy
that'll be like, hey Ron, you know,
put me in a fucking show called, oh
hey Ron, to do that little fucking,
that judo flip. I watched one. This
guy has, you're doing. It's like,
why would you do that?
She's a champion at beating the
shit out of people you think keep,
she never had a fight.
Some broad decides that you are you
sitting there with your man tits,
you should be wearing a sports bra,
sir. She fucking grabbed this dude,
threw him over. I got to give it up
to the guy. If she did that to me,
I think I would've died.
I definitely want to, God,
I remember it back in the
day when you played football,
when the ground was frozen and
when you were a little kid,
I remember the first time you discovered
that you could actually get the wind
knocked out of you by getting hit in the
back. That's what she did to this guy.
She fucking flipped the dude. He was
trying to be wacky. Hey, let me, you know,
let me go up here and uh,
you know,
fuck with this judo champion slash
you up mixed martial arts champion.
She fucking threw him over his hip and
he's laying on the ground and he's making
all these noises and she's laughing,
thinking he's fucking around and he
starts going up. It felt my ribs.
It's just going, oh no. And
he goes, I heard it crack
fucking over a fucking over man.
That would be the funniest shit ever.
If, if you were in a relationship with,
with a woman's UFC champion,
just to just flip that dynamic,
I guess they already made a movie
they made Norbert was like that.
But it would be funnier if she actually
had like judo skills. Like, honey,
I don't want to go to the mall and she
looks at you like, all right, I'm kidding.
My jacket it, nobody would
have sympathy for you.
Allowed your pussy go down to the fucking
strip mall, start taking some classes.
You know, you start taking, you'd
have to take some classes, you know,
on the slide without a no one.
When she comes home,
she thinks she's cheating on her
and she's fucking you. I Dunno,
she's gotten me a triangle.
Right.
And uh,
they will happen is either,
then you tell her that you're taking
the classes or what happens is,
is the next time your play fight and you
try a couple of fucking moves that you
learned, you know, except get thrown
him. Like, I just learned this,
punched down to this at a strip mall,
which she's fought for real,
you know, and maybe it just sets her
off like she can't get, you know,
once she turned one, she flips that
switch. You can't shut it off. Right.
You wake up 40 minutes later, she's
crying. Holding both sides of your head.
I'm sorry baby.
I'm sorry
you did that spinning
back fist and I just, I,
I went somewhere else.
I'm sorry.
Don't want to work the next day. And
your wife knock you out again. Yeah.
Taking all that shit.
Would it be worth it?
I think would be. I think
we would be, I'd be looking,
you gotta teach me some Shit,
right?
Okay.
That'd be awesome. Oh God. I don't know.
Anyways, that's the Monday morning.
I had the Thursday, the
Thursday afternoon, uh,
Monday morning podcast just before Friday.
This is what it's been a,
now we're going to go take you back to
a classic clip from, from way back when?
From a, the end of the Bush years,
or maybe Obama was already an office.
I don't know where they
really, a different president.
I don't think they are.
I think it's the same guy.
I think it's a fucking mannequin.
And they take it out and this time
they decided to stick a little fucking,
a little Afro. One, a little
Ben Vareen Afro, you know,
maybe throw a little salt and pepper in
there. Give him a distinguished look.
That's it. And they just
stick of different voice
recorder in there. Right. Oh,
go fuck yourself. I have theories.
Send me Yours. All right.
Hope you enjoy these classic clips.
And uh, thank you for listening.
I'll talk to you on Monday.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
since you've been traveling across
the country for the past decade or so,
urban legend,
you ever heard of
urban legends? Uh, I've heard so many good
ones. Um, I, well I grew up in the 80s,
so there was a lot of fear
about age during that time.
And um,
I remember there was an urban
legend about a guy's in a bar.
He made this chick, she's totally smoke
and looks like a fucking supermodel.
They go back to her place,
you know, whenever her hotel,
she gives him the best
blowjob Evan at bang.
And I'm inviting the
greatest fucking night ever.
He wakes up the next morning she's gone
and he walks into the bathroom and then
on the mirror is written in lipstick.
Congratulations.
Now we both have age,
cause evidently he didn't use a condom.
And I remember being in a room or in
a warehouse believing every word going
really what we do. Where, where
did that happen? I don't know.
[inaudible] road.
And I was a moron. I liked
that one. And I liked a,
there was another one
out there about a guy,
he meets a girl in a bar
and uh, she says, hey,
and she's totally smoking. And
she says, Hey, this is the deal.
You can come back to my place, you can do
whatever you want to me, but in any end,
I get to do whatever I want to you. Like,
I was like, yeah, sure. Fucking let's go.
So, you know, he does everything you
could possibly do with a woman, you know,
as an orgasm, everything's great.
And she goes, okay, now it's my turn.
And she ties him down to
the bed. Sorry. Like, okay,
she's under this freaky dominator shit,
whatever. She walks out of the room,
closes the door and all of a sudden the
door fucking kicks open and there's a
black dude dressed like Batman. And he
comes in and he fucks the guy in the ass.
And I actually believe that,
like that totally made sense to me.
I was like once again,
where the dad had, but I don't
know, I think it was in Chelsea.
Um, yeah, probably that one.
And then, then anyone, any,
any of the firecracker, urban
legends, you know, for somebody,
put an mat in somebody's back
pocket and blew half his ass off.
I always liked that one. Um,
yeah, I would say that. All right.
And it's the second part
of the question also.
Do you believe and Spooky
Supernatural Shit? Yes and no.
I believe in outer body experiences.
I believe in some sort of,
uh, I dunno, I don't even afterlife,
but so just some shit that we don't,
we don't understand and we can't tap into.
I definitely believe in that,
but I don't believe in ghosts
like there that you know,
that they're going to haunt me. I
just don't get what it goes. Can Do.
You know, it's invisible.
I can't see it. Okay.
So what does it rattles a land
and goes booooo. All right,
man, that I get used to
that. And then, um, you know,
the worst he can just be as a pain in
the ass, just not shit off my dresser.
And then I speak really, and then
I can just fuck with him mentally.
Just torture him SPEC really well.
And maybe that's why.
Maybe that's why you're a ghost.
You ever think about that?
Maybe you're just a content in life and
your punishment is you don't get to go
anywhere and now you're
trapped in my awful apartment,
you know, kind of a fucking
loser ghost. Are you waiting?
Why don't you out there looking up
women's skirts and we get gay ghost punch.
Go fucking float over to Wa
West, uh, West Hollywood.
It's probably a dude's over there.
You know, he'll get their balls.
I ain't what I'm talking about
here. All right. Um, anyways,
he said my girlfriend is obsessed with
that show. Ghost hunter, hunter hunters.
And I find it ridiculous. Uh, yeah,
I find that shows that
shows it's fucking stupid.
It's all all in the editing and they
act like they're going to find something
and they don't and they never quite
get like a good angle on the ghost.
You know? It's like if you
had a good angle on the ghost,
you would've kept the
footage and you would,
it just could've sold it to any network
out there for millions of dollars.
We finally have proof that ghosts exist,
but they never do it.
So we shaky handheld.
All right.
This is something that I think a lot of
white people need because not because
we're more racist than anybody else,
we just get the,
the consequences of us fucking up is so
much harsher than other people because,
uh, you know, we are the gold
standard when it comes to racist.
We are in the driver's seat right now.
We have been in the driver's seat
for awhile, basically beating that.
If we are ignorant ass holes, it has way
more effect than when other people are.
You know, back in the day
when other people were running
shit, that's the thing.
Whoever's on top, if you're
thinking ignorant, uh, that's
what, that's why, you know,
if you're on top and you're
thinking ignorant shit,
you have to be called on it because,
uh,
just cause he cause the effect that
you can have. You know what I mean?
Like if somebody from Bangladesh fucking
hates me, that's such a stupid example.
Okay. That, that's not a race of people.
I don't even know where Bangladesh's
and I gotta be honest with you.
I don't even know if
that's a city or a country.
Bangladesh have ever seen
that on the prices. Right.
You know,
and showcase showdown where selling yet
a Bangladesh and some white trash person
like myself to sit with a
confused look on their face.
Like I don't know where that is.
Is that where the terrorists are?
I don't want to go there, whatever,
like a Filipino people fucking hate me.
That doesn't affect my life.
It doesn't,
I'm not going to go and do a
job interview at, at, you know,
Walmart is not run by Filipinos.
You know what I mean? You know,
not saying there's anything wrong
with Filipinos. All right. See what,
see what I have to do it. There's a
white person, they'll say, I'm saying,
I think that about they'll plead out.
Just we clear hair planner.
I have never had issues.
I got to have a valve and him,
I'll fucking all that shit. You got to go
to the Jerry Lewis voice there lady. Um,
so yeah, people have
questions. So here we go.
And I think all races should chime
in the questions that you have.
If you have feelings about a different
race of people and you just think that
you're thinking something funny, there's
nothing malicious, but is this offensive?
Is it racist? This is, this
is the new topic. Okay.
And if you feel that I answered these
questions like the ignorant white men that
I am, uh, call me out on it. I'm
here. So here we go. This first one,
Bill,
is it racist to call Indians?
Dibble dabbles.
And I'm talking about the Asian ones,
not native Americans, I'm guessing by
Dib and Dab as you mean [inaudible] Oh,
Dubai.
October two baby to you're
saying like that debit Dabu um,
is it racist? Probably,
but it's fucking funny.
So that knocks it down a little bit.
This is what I feel that makes
something like racist. It's like,
like the reason why,
uh,
that one isn't as offensive
is because we haven't,
we never enslaved them. That's the
reason why white and black should,
is so sensitive is because of
the shift that we did to them.
But we haven't really fuck
with those people, you know?
So if the black version of that was,
is it,
is it offensive to black people?
Hey man, mother fucker or whatever.
Yes.
That would be offensive if you did some
sort of mocking of the way they spoke.
Yes.
That would be,
that would be offensive if some CEO was
giving a speech and I was driving a,
actually I was having someone else drive
my town car and we drove by a group of,
uh, and uh, they proceeded
to walk forwards again,
you'd have to apologize. So I guess, yeah,
I guess technically Duma
Dabo like that would be,
that would be offensive. Is it racist? Um,
this is what I, I really, I really,
it's hard for me to say because it had,
it's what's in your heart, you
know, cause I make fuck I really,
I make fun of, of everybody, you know,
I mean I play a game out here. Uh,
when someone is make, let me ask you, I've
got a question for you. Is this racist?
I have a game out here when I ride around
with Nia and she does not approve of
this to keep her in the clear.
She does not approve this.
When somebody makes a more ronic
move in front of me, you know,
driving, you know, just makes
a fucking horrific move.
I play a game called old or Asian
and you have to guess when,
cause I'm going to pass the person
cause I got to see what they look like.
You know, whenever somebody
does something fucked up,
some comedians do great joke about that.
You just want to see what the fuck they
look like. Right. Uh, that's the game.
Older Asian. So as I speed up my little
hybrid to try to pull parallel to them,
I always say what he's saying here, what
are you going with all the regime, what?
He got older Asian, she goes, I'm
not playing this game. That's mean,
and then I was gone. I'm going to
go with old and then I pull up, oh,
it's fucking Asian, you know, or
Oh, I nailed it. It was an old guy.
So is that racist?
I'm sure it's offensive,
but within the context of my own car,
you know,
I'm not yelling at anybody
and I got to admit, you know,
there's a lot of truth in the
fucking game. Yeah. Jesus,
I'm gonna have to apologize next week on
the podcast. So I would say that, uh, uh,
Indian people, why don't you
chime in? I would say that, yeah.
That they would find that they
would find that offensive. Um,
is it racist? Let me see if I
can use it in a sentence here.
Hey, uh, you know, I called up
customer service and, uh, you know,
one of those stupid dog was answered
and tried to tell me that his name was
Steve and act like he was in Kentucky.
But I,
I know that he was actually an India,
cause what he talked to,
he was going Dubak Dabo Woods.
How could I help you? Um,
is it racist?
Probably.
Okay.
You know what, something bad has to
happen between white culture and, uh, or,
or western culture in Indians.
So, you know what I mean?
It's like a, it's like you're playing
a team and there's no rivalry.
Like patriots verse jets this
year was like a whites and blacks.
It was bad. It was a
lot of hate, you know,
but like patriots verse,
like the Fucking Lions,
you know? Yeah. There's going to be
some shit targets. It's knocked out,
but it still hurts if
somebody says something mean.
I don't really know what the fuck
I'm talking about. All right,
let's move to the next one.
The next one on the new controversial
topic on the Monday morning podcast.
Is it racist? All right, here we go. Um,
Bill, I had an interesting experience
today apparently involving me as a racist.
I was walking with two of my coworkers
who are both black. Oh Geez. Here we go.
Um,
we were going to go get some lunch.
One of my coworkers who are
most of friends with, uh,
did a little high five fist bump shuffle
with one of the female six security
guards at the front desk.
Knowing both of them and how
they interact with one another.
I kind of made a in passing
comment to the tune of man,
you guys in your handshakes
while obviously laughing,
laughing while obviously laughing at
just how choreographed it was in more or
less picturing them in
a studio or something,
working out the logistics to get the
fucking handshake. Perfect. Anyways,
we all laughed and moved on and
we got our lunch. All right,
so nothing wrong yet.
So you're cool with these people.
You made a joke and everybody laughed.
No problems,
no problems so far. Um, however,
after coming back through secure,
uh,
back through security,
I noticed the security guard stopped
me and Kinda had a scowl on her face.
I thought she was mad at me for something,
but it turned out she was mad at this
other lady who was black because she
overheard my comment and was telling,
uh,
that security guard that she couldn't
believe I had the nerve to say something
like that and I should be ashamed
all set to the point where she could,
um,
almost to the point where she could
actually go complain to the human resource
people because she was
offended, um, et Cetera,
without even considering that.
Maybe just maybe I was talking about the
security guard and my coworker and not
all black people now.
It being corporate America in all I'm
sure rather than even face apos pos
possibility of any bad press,
they'd rather just sweep me out the
door and completely ruined my re any
reputation I may or may not hold at the
company just to save their own assets.
I feel I did nothing wrong and had no
intentions of ever doing anything wrong.
Anything wrong.
I'm not going to go on and on about
how I kissed black babies and trying to
rehabilitate inner city
schools because I don't,
but I'm certainly not some corn fed rebel
flag waving ignorant product of what
might be incest.
I guess my question is do we really have
to walk on eggshells when we're just
making casual conversation that just
any that just any con can pick apart,
select the context that they might think
it is in and then start crying foul.
Basically.
I would have liked to call that woman
a cunt and told her to go fuck herself,
but let's just say I was already
kind of worried about my job.
All right. See, um, yeah, I think this is,
this is the classic one where you were
fucking around the other two people knew
you were fucking around,
but the one person decides to get
offended and then you have to go on TV and
apologize.
Which personally I think is the wrong
move because when you apologize now it's
like you're, you're admitting that you
meant it in a bad way. I mean the apology,
I would do that and say, look, you know,
I'm sorry that you didn't
understand that I was joking,
but I'm not going to sit here
and apologize like I have any,
any sort of ill will come in your way,
you know,
but I, but just to avoid
the problem in the future,
uh,
white people do not use the
expression you guys or you people
when talking about black people, that's
just it. It's just not going to, you're,
you're setting yourself up for
someone to get offended. And, um,
there's a weird sort of a push
pull going on with that whole, uh,
you guys and New People thing where I'm
with somebody white says that
there becomes this concern of,
um, that you're separating.
You're separating like, yeah,
you know,
you people over there with how you
live your lives and where over here,
black people have that weird relationship
with white people where they're like,
you know, can you stop stealing
our fucking music and our culture?
But then like, if something,
you know, hey, let's pave
the streets, you know, well,
make sure you do it in our neighborhood.
We're all in this together, right.
All of us together.
You know what I mean?
So it's that weird sort of fucking
push, pull thing going on. So yeah,
just avoid, uh, avoid the whole fucking,
um, yeah, you fucked up.
You didn't fuck up, but you,
you left yourself open for a
sucker punched by saying you guys,
you know, uh, that's, I guess that, that's
what it is. I don't know. That's, that's,
that's my, I basically a white guy
telling a white guy how he fucked up.
So black people feel listening
to this. Think, uh, please,
please help me out here.
Did I basically get it right?
Is that essentially it?
And I know most people wouldn't get
offended. All right. So there you go.
That's the new, that's the new topic.
Is it racist? And I would love to hear,
um, some honest comments from a
nonwhite people about their thoughts.
You know, the fucked up ones too. Okay.
Cause I've watched enough spike Lee movies
to think that evidently it's just us,
but I've hung around enough people from
different races to realize, oh yeah,
everybody's like,
[inaudible]
[inaudible].